>> Sean: HERE WITH REACTION --
[LAUGHS]
NOT VERY GOOD, QUITE FRANKLY.
FORMER BUSH OF ADMINISTRATION
DEPUTY HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF, THE
ARCHITECT, KARL ROVE.
WE WILL GET TO THE COGNITIVE
QUESTION WITH DR. RONNIE
JACKSON.
WE ARE THREE WEEKS FROM TONIGHT,
THERE’S NOBODY KNOWS WHERE
CUYAHOGA COUNTY IS, WHERE
HAMILTON COUNTY IS, I CAN GO
THROUGH ALL THE COUNTIES AND YOU
KNOW THEM ALL AND WHAT THEY
MEAN.
HOW DO YOU SEE THE RAYS THREE
WEEKS OUT?
I THINK THERE IS AN EFFORT
URGING PEOPLE TO NEVER TRUST THE
MEDIA.
>> I WANT TO GO BACK TO WHAT YOU
STARTED WITH BECAUSE IT REALLY
IS ASTONISHING.
THINK ABOUT THIS.
THIS IS SORT OF -- IT’S NOT AS
BAD AS DEPLORABLES, AND YOU KNOW
THEY CLING TO THEIR GUNS, BUT
WHAT THE JOE BIDEN JUST SAY?
JOE BIDEN SAID YOU’RE STUPID.
HE SAID YOU CAN’T FIGURE OUT
WHAT AFFECTS YOU IN YOUR LIFE
AND THE PROSPERITY OF YOUR
FAMILY AND COMMUNITY.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
YOU’RE RIGHT, RONALD REAGAN
ASKED THE QUESTION AND THE ONE
DEBATE IN 1980, ARE YOU BETTER
OFF THAN YOU WERE FOUR YEARS
AGO?
GALLUP SMARTLY HAS PICKED IT UP
AND ASK THAT QUESTION EVER
SINCE.
TODAY, YOU’RE RIGHT, 50% OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE SAY I’M BETTER
OFF.
AMAZING!
WE ARE IN A PANDEMIC.
10.7 MILLION MORE PEOPLE ARE
WITHOUT JOBS TODAY.
WHY DO 56% SAY THAT?
I THINK THEY SAY IT BECAUSE IN
2017, 2018, 2019 AND THROUGH
FEBRUARY OF THIS YEAR, THEY WERE
ENJOYING BETTER PROSPERITY THAN
THEY HAD BEEN ENJOYING FOR YEARS
AND THEY GIVE PRESIDENT TRUMP
CREDIT FOR IT.
BY COMPARISON, IN 2012, IN THE
FINAL MONTHS OF BARACK OBAMA’S
REELECTION, THAT NUMBER WAS 45%
AND IN 2004, JUST BEFORE BUSH
GOT REELECTED, IT WAS 47%, BUT
56%, IT SAYS SOMETHING ABOUT THE
SENSE OF PROSPERITY IN THE SENSE
THAT WE ARE BETTER OFF AND LIFE
IS BETTER AND THE OPPORTUNITIES
ARE BIGGER AND WE’VE GOT MORE
OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR FAMILY AND
OUR FUTURE AND OUR COMMUNITY --
TODAY, EVEN WITH ALL THE
DIFFICULTIES WE’VE GOT.
IT SHOWS THE STRENGTH OF THE
ECONOMIC ISSUE, THE ISSUE OF WHO
CAN BETTER RESTART THE ECONOMY
IS ONE THAT DONALD TRUMP CAN
BEAT JOE BIDEN ON, BUT HE’S GOT
TO DO WHAT HE DID THE OTHER
NIGHT, AND THAT HIS FOCUS ON IT
AND DO THE FOLLOWING.
HE’S GOT TO HAVE A NARRATIVE.
HE’S GOT TO ESTABLISH A
NARRATIVE.
THIS IS WHAT’S CRITICAL AS WE
COME DOWN THE PIKE.
IN 2016, HE HAD A NARRATIVE,
WHICH IS WASHINGTON IS BROKEN,
YOU NEED SOMEBODY TO GO IN AND
DISRUPTED, I AM THE AGENT OF
CHANGE AND HERE’S WHAT I’M GOING
TO DO, I’M GOING TO RESTORE OUR
ECONOMY, GET THE RELATIONSHIP
RIGHT WITH CHINA, MAKE AMERICA’S
MILITARY STRONG AGAIN AND BUILD
THAT WALL.
EVERYBODY KNEW WHAT HIS
NARRATIVE WAS.
HE NEEDS TO HAVE THAT SAME
NARRATIVE, THAT SAME CLARITY
COMING DOWN THE PIKE HERE AND I
THINK THE NARRATIVE IS THIS.
JOE BIDEN IS NOT SHOOTING
STRAIGHT WITH YOU.
HE SAID HE WAS AGAINST FRACKING
IN THE PRIMARIES, NOW HE SAYS
HE’S FOR IT.
SAID DURING THE PRIMARIES AND
CONTINUES TO SAY I’M GOING TO
GET RID OF THE PROMPT TAX CUTS
AND THEN TURNS AROUND AND SAYS
I’M NOT GOING TO TAX ANYBODY WHO
MAKES LESS THAN 400 MORE -- I’M
NOT GOING TO TAX ANYBODY WHO
MAKES THEM KNOW MIKE LESS THAN
$400,000 A YEAR.
YOU’RE NOT SHOOTING STRAIGHT.
HE SAID SOMETHING EARLIER IN THE
YEAR AND THEN SAID SOMETHING
ELSE DIFFERENT.
HE SAID IN A PRIMERA NOT GOING
TO ATTACK THE SUPREME COURT AND
NOW HE SAYS YOU’LL KNOW MY
OPINION AFTER THE ELECTION, YOU
DUMMIES.
YOU DON’T KNOW DESERVE -- YOU
DON’T DESERVE TO KNOW WHAT I’M
THINKING ABOUT UNTIL AFTER THE
ELECTION IS OVER.
NOT SHOOTING STRAIGHT WITH THE
VOTERS IN THE OTHER PART OF IT
IS, HE ADMITS HE WANTS TO BE THE
MOST PROGRESSIVE PRESIDENT IN
HISTORY.
THAT MEANS HE WANTS TO BE THE
MOST LEFT-WING PRESIDENT WE’VE
EVER HAD AND ALWAYS GOT TO DO
AND HOW THE PRESIDENT NEEDS TO
DO IS GO TO THE DEMOCRATIC
PLATFORM AND GO TO THE
BIDEN-SANDERS UNITY TASK FORCE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND GO AROUND
THE COUNTRY SAYING HERE’S WHAT
HE SAID, HERE’S WHAT HE WANTS TO
DO.
HE LED YOU TO BELIEVE HE WAS A
DIFFERENT KIND OF GUY, A
TRADITIONAL DEMOCRAT IN THE
PRIMARIES, NOW HE’S SHOWING HIS
TRUE COLORS, BUT DENYING THAT
HE’S IN FAVOR OF ALL THESE
THINGS THAT HE’S ENDORSED IN A
PLATFORM AND IN A UNITY
RECOMMENDATION AND TRUMP CAN DO
THAT.
I SAW A GUY THE OTHER NIGHT WHO
WAS THE HAPPY WARRIOR.
HE CAME OUT, HE WAS LIGHT, HE
DID A LITTLE DANCE.
HE SAID -- HE HAD A SMILE ON HIS
FACE, HE DELIVERED THE ATTACKS
WITH NOT A GRIM LOOK ON HIS
FACE, BUT LIKE HE WAS ENJOYING
IT, AND THAT’S THE KIND OF
GUY -- IF HE WANTS TO WIN,
THAT’S WHAT HE’S GOT TO DO IN
THE NEXT 20 DAYS.
>> Sean: KARL ROVE, THE
ARCHITECT.
I WOULD JUST SAY ANYBODY THAT
MAKES A PREDICTION, I DON’T
TRUST ANYBODY.
YOU SAW THE EXIT POLLS IN 2004,
WHAT DID THEY SAY?
REFRESH MY MEMORY.
>> WELL, THE EXIT POLLS IN THE
AFTERNOON EXIT POLLS SAID BUSH
WAS TIED IN MISSISSIPPI LOSING
WHITE MEN IN FLORIDA, GETTING
WIPED OUT IN NORTHTH CAROLINA AN
MINNESOTA, AND OHIO AND
COLORADO.
>> Sean: JOHN HENRY --
JOHN KERRY WAS GOING TO BE THE
NEXT PRESIDENT.
>> THEY WENT IN AND TOLD HIM
CONGRATULATIONS, MR. PRESIDENT.
YOU’RE GOING TO THE OCCUPANT OF
THE OVAL OFFICE AND THE MEDIA
BELIEVED IT.
I REMEMBER THAT AFTERNOON WHILE,
WE CALLED AROUND TO ALL THE
MEDIA SAYING THIS IS NOT RIGHT.
THREE QUARTERS OF THE VOTERS IN
MINNESOTA AND NORTH CAROLINA ARE
NOT WOMEN.
WELL, MAYBE HE CHANGED THE
NATURE OF THE ELECTORATE.
BUT LOOK, I’M WORRIED LESS ABOUT
ELECTION NIGHT THEN BETWEEN NOW
AND THEN -- BETWEEN NOW AND THEN
THE PRESIDENT NEEDS TO HAVE THAT
SAME DISCIPLINE.
HE WAS FOCUSED THE OTHER NIGHT,
HE NEED TO HAVE THAT SAME
DISCIPLINE IN 2016.
HE GOT UP AND MOCKED
REINCE PRIEBUS AND STEVE BANNON
AND KELLYANNE CONWAY AND SAID
THEY TOLD ME TO STAY ON SCRIPT
AND HE MOCKED THEM BUT THAT
DISCIPLINE WAS GOOD.
I SAW SOME OF THAT DISCIPLINE
THE OTHER NIGHT.
IF HE WANTS TO WIN IS HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE THE DISCIPLINE.
ONE OTHER THING.
HE’S A SHOWMAN.
HE NEEDS TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO
THIS.
FOR EXAMPLE, BUT, WHY NOT GET
ONE OF THOSE BIG SCREENS AND
WHEN HE’S TALKING ABOUT HOW
BIDEN IS NOT SHOOTING STRAIGHT
LIKE ON FRACKING, GO TO
PENNSYLVANIA, BE IN FRONT OF A
PLANT -- ONE OF THE CHEMICAL
PLANTS THAT’S THEIR BECAUSE THEY
GOT THE NATURAL GAS REVOLUTION
OCCURRING THERE.
TALK ABOUT JOBS.
RUNNING THE PLAN.
AND THEN SAY -- NOW HE SAYS --
HERE’S WHAT HE WAS SAYING DURING
THE PRIMARY, LET’S GO TO THE
VIDEOTAPE.
HERE’S WHAT HE SAYS, PUT ARE
SEVEN OR EIGHT, HAVE HIM SAYING
IT AND THEN NOW WHAT DOES HE
SAY?
KAMALA HARRIS UP THERE AND PUT
THE PRESIDENT -- AND PUT THE
VICE PRESIDENT UP THERE AND
SAYING HE IS NOT SHOOTING
STRAIGHT WITH YOU, GO TO THE
VIDEOTAPE.
>> Sean: WAIT A MINUTE, THAT
WILL BECOME THE EQUIVALENT OF
THE KARL ROVE WHITEBOARD.
WE WILL CALL IT THE DONALD TRUMP